2階とイケてるなおっ
意外とイケてる
意外とイケてる今ちゃうぜこんにちははじめ社長ですお久しぶりです連坊コーン
シャーペイ総理機会はだいぶ減ったんですけどもシャーペンの像はちゃんと毎回入れて
おりますけどねしゃべん場外もちょっと張り切ってず待ってるのか知んないんですけど
デルガードをレンズ振るとか彼のここらへんこの3つが出てからちょっとでなかなか
新しい商品が出なくなりましてもう年あれだ
アプリゲームとかよくあるじゃない強いキャラが出すぎてその強いキャラがに強い
キャラが香典なくなっちゃうんですよねその今出てるをレンズでレガードプルート語り
が強すぎるんでなかなかそれをこそ新しいシャーペンが出ないと動いシャーペンなら僕
も招待したいですよ懲戒したんですけどもなかなかこう新しいしゃべってキャラ出て
ないんで
悲しいだけで学生が終わっても三平は全然好きなのでちょっとこんなにすごいこれは
もうやないよっていうのを聞きました
お砂糖牛肉で箱を持ってきたっていうね結構スタメンのサーフィン増えてきたんです
けども昔めちゃくちゃあー染めたこちらのシャーペン覚えてますでしょうか
こちらスマッシュでございます製図用シャーペン近い細さを持つこのシャーペン
グリップもつぶつぶで何と言ってもた
履き心地がすごい気持ちというシャーペンスマッシュでございます俺の本名が帰って
特徴としてはここは先っちょですね普通のシャンペンならたぶんこの黒いここで止まっ
て写真が出るんですけどもうちょっとゲームの土地が伸びて校から出てるので
10時のシャッター基本的にこの作りなんですけれども自分がどこで字を書いているの
かが分かりやすいというかピンポイントで字が書けます
たまんない室は今回なんと
なんとですねスマッシュのオリジナルカラーの含まれておりました
ん
あの
すごいれてはこれはかなりすごいことですますのれじゃないから
を吸って販売されたんですけどもう販売され場所の56本だけという6度限定の
スマッシュのオリジナルからこそが出たというわけで終わってもこの投票に
グランディスぞの駅前にあるロフトニームを打っているスマホのサーフィンつも買って
きました
[音楽]
うわぁこちらでございましょうかよねもう本当にこのスマッシュの新色カラーが出たと
いうことがそこだした鳥栖月の素晴らしさを再確認する動画でございます
学生の皆様いらっしゃいません50という展開されております
ああああああ
一色ていないばあ
rar
技術れてましたこちらの4署がカッコしました
白緑ピンク青でございますでもう一色僕とちかというとそっちへちゃん欲しかったん
ですけども
アカクロアたが売ってたんですけどもどうやら人気席で酒造家がある人には売ってませ
んでした
か自分薄かったのではちょっと涙もちょっと動きが遅かった
もうちょっと情報を仕入れてすぐ買いに行けば書いてあるんでしょうけど中の人に行く
時間がなくて行けなってまずこの4色はゲットしたんですけどちょっとこの辺で見て
いきましょう色で咲い順番に見ていきましょうまずはこちら見たいです棒で今度ね
なんかでも済ませ
このカラーのイメージしかないからまさかのいずれかが出ると僕も思ってませんでした
ああたまんないよこのフォルム美味しい
これで g かける時代生まれた君たちは本当に幸せもんだよ続いて白白後で何かね
色長がねあーねこれはあまり好きじゃねーよね正直によって後ろあんまり好きじゃな
いってはなんかによくいるじゃないですか降ればこう白黒で統一している
かくし芸女子みたいな牛芸女子の人はたぶんこういう
のが出るのかなと思いますしたのか消えたらもう僕は細すべてピンクもねかっこいいね
ちょっとビビったけどで来いってなんですけどもできる方になってくるんですね
僕アンカーを抜いたらさんは青が一番好きなんですよどうでしょうかね
おいよ勉強されなっちゃうこれで勉強できるんですよが手に入ったらこちらの姑息で
ございます安定した着心地で天井ならである政府にかける感覚後歳児なんですけどもう
来たゲット比べると結構粘れと粗面なんで僕みたいに手が大きい人だとちょっと眼
小さく感じることがあるのでそこは注意しましょう
おかしいと感じました今なので仕掛けるっスよ明日風
おっ
[音楽]
何て言いまスマッシュで g 書こうとしてたんだけどねスマッシュ2にそれをずっと
恐れ
ねえ数カーね今東京だよメインの回ですか
いや多分今日帰れねえんだよねー
たそんなんで0た行ってきてほしいえっ
深いてみる1回でいいですね
ネイル分の incarose
これが解の公式で x の値が何かがわかるそういう式になっている
そういう話ではない一番何を見てほしいかというとやっぱりでもここですねその政治を
さペンならではの神の部分が長いのでどこで一応書いているかグラフをどういう風に
書いているかはっきりわかるということを言ってことにっ
はい次でスマホを使ういろんな一番の似顔絵を書いてみました妖
んだから細かく描けるんですよね開いてゆけいかがだったでしょうかスマッシュ目立ち
済ませの動画だした時スマッシュ
使ってみてすごい良かったよ人が多かったんで一回使ってみてほしいです何でなるべく
シャーペイナビ姉こう自分がかキャス8選んでほしいんですけどもその一つ
やっぱりこのしまして大変お勧めでございませんやっぽるやんか黒が欲しかった
東京のロットとか売ってないかなちょっと行ってみようか
ちなみにペンテルさんのホームページのネット販売を全て売り切れでございますまあ皆
さんの loft に売ってたら買ったらぜひ買ってみてください
マジでお勧めのこれさえあれば大学受験ここ付も上へ的な嘘で
[音楽]
me
じゃあなー
嬉しいなぁ